- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is have an impact.
Over to you, Chris Sacca.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Too many investors
invest in the things that
they just like and are comfortable with
and are within their own
little bubble, and yet,
I think the distinction we like to make is
invest in things that we know we can
personally impact the outcome of.
So everyone can be talking about the hot
biotech deal and it might be
on the verge of curing cancer,
but I cannot do anything
to advance the mission
of a biotech company.
Quite literally.
And so we passed.
As cool as it may seem,
if I'm going to mooch,
I may as well mooch in
the public markets, right,
and just throw darts and
ride the greens and reds.
So if I believe that I can take something
that's already a good company
and just make it a little
more likely to be a success,
then that's a rigged game for me.
It almost feels unfair, right?
And I can be just that much more confident
that the investors who
give me their money,
I'm going to give them their
money back and a lot more after that.
- So as an investor myself,
it's something that I look at.
I want to make sure that
I'm invested into businesses
that I believe in,
that I can add something to,
that I can inject some creativity
and leverage what I've done
with my audience and
YouTube and my website,
and not just invest in somebody
'cause their thing looks cool,
but I think the more valuable message
to you guys who are probably more
in the entrepreneurial side
than the investor side
is you need to apply the same kind
of thinking when you're
looking for investors.
So when you are going out
looking for someone to give you money
to launch your business,
expand your business,
especially when you're dealing
with angel investors
or venture capitalists,
you want the people who can
give you more than just money.
It may be great to think about your
uncle Joe or aunt Jill or whoever it is,
you know, the dentist down the street
or the doctor that you know
or that lawyer friend of
yours to give you money.
Which you don't want
what's called dumb money.
You don't want people
to just give you money
and that's it,
because your biggest
thing is not just money.
You want somebody who
cares about your business,
who doesn't see it only as an investment,
who cares about the
mission that you're on,
and that can open doors for you.
That can give guidance to you.
Right, you want somebody who
you can ask questions to,
and they can give you some mentorship.
You want somebody who's going
to open up their rolodex
of contacts and make introductions
for you to help you close new deals,
to help you get more media,
to help you get new suppliers,
and get more customers on board.
And so I'd highly, highly, highly
encourage you,
anybody who's out there trying
to raise money for their business,
don't bring on any investor
just because you need money.
You have to get the
right investor on board.
And that's hard to do.
Because when you're struggling
and you really need that cash
and it's really hurting your growth,
the tendency is,
I'll take anybody because I
want to ramp up my growth.
But you're making a long-term
decision based on short-term needs.
And the last thing you want to do
is get stuck with an investor
who isn't going to be a
fit for you long-term.
Right, they're going to always own
a piece of your company
and the more and more people
that own a chunk of your business,
that don't actually contribute
anything besides money to you,
you don't want those guys
on your company at all.
So the question of the day today is
we haven't talked a lot about investing,
investments, getting
investors into your company,
I'm curious for you guys,
are you looking at angel investments?
Have you already gone
down that route or not?
Where are you on your path?
Are you going to self-fund it?
Try to get investments?
Try to get loans?
Where are you on your path
of raising capital?
I'm curious to find out,
leave it in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Andrew Bierkamp.
Andrew, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
it really really really really
means a lot to me,
and I hope you enjoy it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I hope you have an amazing day.
I believe in you
and hope you continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going